hey guys so the neo alpha has just come
out on the PlayStation Store and Tay and
I have been playing a lot of it lately
and it's brought back some memories of
Dark Souls 3 which is still pretty fresh
in our minds what did you think of it I
thought Neil was a lot of fun
it's very Dark Souls II in a way because
of you know the stamina and and just how
brutal it is in terms of you know making
mistakes and trying to learn what your
opponents are doing but at the same time
it was blending other fun things like
Onimusha where you had very weapon based
skills that you know if you had an X
that could play differently than if you
had a katana and those things are
interesting to me I mean yes there are
multiple weapons and Dark Souls but in
neo you actually level up your weapons
skills yeah I liked how you could unlock
new skills like one with the axe in
particular if you hold down triangle
you'd like basically do like a sort of
Legend of Zelda spin move with it but
then you'd also did point out the
stamina which is huge in this game it
stamina is definitely something you need
to keep an eye on in this yeah so
stamina in this game is somewhat similar
to Dark Souls where you know your
actions take up some of your stamina
running etc takes up your stamina but
the big difference here and the most
punishing thing about it is if you do
run out of stamina your guy just keels
over and he sits there and pants and
goes oh god I'm so tired I gotta I gotta
take a break in that moment if you're
stuck there and out of stamina you are
so open to attacks and these attacks in
this game hurts so bad I've been
multiple times I've been to shotted
maybe three shot at it and a lot of the
times is because you're out of stamina
you're stuck there I don't know if this
is the thing that they're gonna keep in
the game because it is an alpha I hope
that maybe they get rid of the keel over
thing cuz I think it's a little bit too
much and it sucks sitting there and
standing there and just being like I
can't do anything
this stamina was definitely brutal and
there were plenty of times where I'd be
fighting off enemies and if you ran up
stamina and you're still there's still
two left you're as good as dead yeah I
will mention though that at least with
the like lower stance attack which is
another thing they have in the game
there's multiple stances there's like a
high stance of a mid stance and a low
stance that each attack differently but
with a low stance I was able to kind of
attack a couple times and then I was
able to do that the dodge or the dash
back and it would kind of highlight in
white and then I would
stamina back so I couldn't do that with
the the medium stance or the high stance
but it seemed like a good way to kind of
you know get your stamina back from when
I found the hi stencil can't like the
heavier one mm-hmm and one cool thing
that I found out is that when an enemy
falls on the ground I'd switched to my
high stance and then I just like crush
him from above like with an axe or
whatever whatever it was that I was
using what did you think of the world
how is that as compared to Dark Souls I
guess I'm into it it's it's interesting
because you have not only just human
enemies that you're fighting against but
there's also like zombified like a demon
type and he's too so there's kind of a
little bit of both you know kind of dark
souls he's - you kind of have humanoid
and monsters but yeah I totally like the
environment and and the setting I like
this oriental style that they have going
on it's different from the Dark Souls
that we were used to and you know the
the layout of the land
there's shortcuts I don't know if you've
gone around and found those but there's
like one of them yeah yeah like you're
kicking that ladders like oh this gets
me to you know the the little shrine
that you pray at which is essentially
like a bonfire so this brings us sort of
to the biggest question I think a lot of
people have would you say it's more
hardcore than Dark Souls and keep in
mind that it is still an alpha so a lot
of these things that we might be judging
or complaining about could very much
change I think that at least from my
first playthrough it felt harder FEM
Dark Souls only because it was more
unforgiving in the sense that one the
stamina if you ran out you would keel
over and that would pretty much be an
insta-kill if the guys were next to you
almost they happen to run out of stamina
and - because as I mentioned earlier the
damage output of the AI versus like how
much life you had is pretty insane like
just dying from two hits barely happens
in dark souls outside of if you're
fighting something pretty strong right
like what boss exactly but some of these
just normal guys with the katana wool
maybe not the normal guys with the
katana but like those guys might be
three hits but still three hits right
like in Dark Souls you could probably
take three hits and still kind of live
and then kind of fend off whoever he was
and try to get to a bonfire I don't know
what do you think do you think it's
harder than dark souls I I think I had a
bit more trouble with it than you did
and yeah I think it's definitely harder
than Dark Souls but I pretty much echo
the things that you were saying like I
think it's more so of the mechanics
rather than like sort of the enemies
you're fighting you know like how Dark
Souls a lot of the challenge
from the bosses you're fighting the
moves characters do and this is just
kind of feels like you know you take
three hits and you die one thing I did
notice though is that I didn't feel as
accomplished when I get through an area
as I did with Dark Souls I don't think
the difficulty curve is where it should
be you know like I'd have lots of
trouble on something and then I've died
and then I do it again and I die and I'd
do it again and I'd die and then I'd
finally get through it and I'd feel good
but it wasn't like I didn't get that
same rewarding feeling that I do in Dark
Souls which is why I'm kind of hesitant
to play the full game when it comes out
but yeah it is an alpha so it will most
likely change yeah I mean I definitely
agree with you I did beat the the demo
and I still never really got that
resounding joy of like oh yeah I just
beat that boss that was whooping me like
even though that boss kicked my butt I
didn't feel like that I didn't have my
stand-up moment where I just in Dark
Souls I'd get up and kind of fist pump I
didn't have that that might be a problem
but yeah we'll see thanks Jake yeah
thank you
neo right now is in alpha you can
download the demo on PSN and stay tuned
GameSpot for more on neo and Dark Souls